[موسيقى]
في خضم ازمه ثقه بالنظام المصرفي اضطرابات
في سوق الاسهم الاوروبيه
وشبحوا ازمه ماليه عالميه
[موسيقى]
نتنياهو يخفف من خطته لتغيير النظام
القضائي بعد احتجاجات غير مسبوقه منذ اكثر
من شهرين
باستخدام شهادات مشوهه للتاثير على
انتخابات 2024
نبدا نشر من زياره الرئيس الصيني
لموسكو حيث قال الرئيس الروسي
ان موسكو تلقت باهتمام مبادره الصين لحل
الازمه في اوكرانيا
وستناقشها وتنظر لها بعين الاحترام على حد
تعبيره وخلال استقبال نظيره الصيني في
موسكو اشاره بوتين الى ان حجم التبادل
التجاري بين روسيا والصين بلغ
185 مليار دولار واكد بوتين لنظيره الصيني
ان هناك الكثير من الاهداف والمهام
المشتركه
للبلدين بدوره شدد الرئيس الصيني على
بلاده مهتمه بتطوير العلاقات مع روسيا لان
البلدين جيران وشركاء استراتيجيون على حد
قوله
قبل ذلك قال شيجنبينج انه مستعد للعمل مع
روسيا على حمايه النظام العالمي والقانون
الدولي الرئيس الصيني اكد ان التطور
العلاقات بين الصين وروسيا يصبوا في مصلحه
العالم باسره في الاثناء دعت لندن الرئيس
الصيني للضغط على بوتين لوقف الحرب في
اوكرانيا
من جهته قال المتحدث باسم الخارجيه
الصينيه وانك ان زياره الرئيس الى روسيا
تهدف الى تعزيز العلاقات بين البلدين
مؤكدا موقف الصين الموضوعي على حد وصفه
بشان الحرب الاوكرانيه الروسيه
زياره الرئيس هي رحله صداقه وتعاون وسلام
وستجري مناقشه الرئيس بوتين حول العلاقات
الثنائيه والقضايا الدوليه والاقليميه
لتعزيز التنسيق الاستراتيجي بين البلدين
وضخ زخم جديد في تنميه العلاقات كما سيطبق
البلدان مبادئ عدم الانحياز وعدم استهداف
الاطراف الثالثه كما سيعززان اطفاء
الطابعه الديمقراطيه على العلاقات الدوليه
وبناء نمط عالمي متعدد الاقطاب بجانب
تحسين الحوكمه العالميه الصين ستتمسك
بموقفها الموضوعي والعادل بشان الازمه
الاوكرانيه وستلعب دورا بناء في تعزيز
محادثات السلام
يبدو انك تعول هي الاخرى على زياره الرئيس
الصيني لموسكو حيث دعت وزاره الخارجيه
الاوكرانيه لان يستغل شيجمي نفوذه للضغط
على موسكو لوقف الحرب ونقلت وكاله فرانس
على المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الاوكرانيه
قوله ان كيف تتابع عن كتب زياره الرئيس
الصيني لروسيا وتتوقع ان تستخدم نفوذها
على موسكو لوضع حد للحرب في اوكرانيا
بتزامن مع قمه شيما بوتين ما هي خطه بكين
المكونه من 12 بدنا لتحقيق السلام في
اوكرانيا والتي قال عنها شئنها تمثل اكبر
قدر ممكن من وحده وجهات النظر للمجتمع
الدولي
كين لتحقيق السلام في اوكرانيا استئنافه
محادثات السلام احترام سياده كل الدول
التخلي عن عقليه الحرب البارده وقف
الاعمال العدائيه ايجاد حل للازمه
الانسانيه حمايه المدنيين وتبادل اسرى
الحرب الحفاظ على سلامه المنشات النوويه
تقليص الاخطار الاستراتيجيه تسهيل تصدير
الحبوب وقف العقوبات احاديه الجانب الحفاظ
على استقرار سلاسل الصناعه والتوريد دعموا
مرحله اعاده الاعمار
وانضم الينا موسكو مراسل العربيه عبد
الجواد الرشد اهلا بكعب الجواد لا زالت
الى الان الاخبار العاجله والانباء حول
تصريحات الرئيسين الصيني والروسيه تصل
تباعا لو تجمل لنا ابرز مدارا في اللقاء
القمه بين الزعيمين
مرحبا ابراهيم نعم بالفعل يعني هو لقاء
بروتوكولي حتى هذه اللحظه تحدث فيه
الزعيمان الروسي والصيني عن الملفات التي
ستكون على طاوله الحوار لم يتحدثوا طبعا
عن كافه الملفات لكن الازمه الاوكرانيه
والوضع في العالم بما يخص قضايا الامن كان
محور هذا الحديث البروتوكولي طبعا الرئيس
الصيني لعل ابرز ما تحدث عنه هو ان الوضع
العالمي دفع وحتم على موسكو وبكين هذه
الاستراتيجيه في التعاون بالاضافه الى
الكثير من الملفات التي تربط موسكو وبكين
ان كانت سياسيه او اقتصاديه او تعاون على
مختلف الاصعده طبعا بوتين استقبل الرئيس
الصيني وتحدث عن ان موسكو درست بعنايه
المقترح الصيني لحل الازمه الاوكرانيه وان
هذا المحور سيكون اساسيا خلال لقاء
الرئيسين اما مساء اليوم او يوم غد في
اللقاء الم ابراهيم هناك لقاء معلن بين
الرئيسين الروسي والصيني سيجري يوم غد
ولقاء معلن اخر سيجمع الرئيس الصيني مع
الرئيس الحكومه الروسيه ميسوتشين لذلك
طبعا يعني ابراهيم ملفات كثيره طبعا راحت
راحت الصين تتحدث على لساني زعيمها بانها
على ثقه بان موسكو مقدمه على خطوات وتقدم
بينما الجانب الروسي ايضا تحدث وهنئ
ارزعيم الصيني باعاده انتخابه لولايه
ثالثه طبعا الملفات اصبحت معروفه بشكل
كبير ابراهيم على ما يبدو ان الازمه
الاوكرانيه ستشغل حيزا كبيرا منها التعاون
بين البلدين والوضع الامن العالمي في
الكثير من المناطق الاستراتيجيه بين
الجلابين توقيع اتفاقيات اقتصاديه وغير
ذلك طبعا سنشهده خلال زياره الرئيس الصيني
التي تستمر حتى الثاني والعشرين من الشهر
الجاري لابد من لفت الانتباه ابراهيم بان
يعني وفدا كان باستقبال الرئيس الصيني على
بوابه لم يكن بوتين حاضرا حسب البروتوكول
الروسي الزياره بدات عند الساعه يعني
الرابعه وثمانيه وثلاثين دقيقه بالتوقيت
المحلي تم الاعلان عن هذه الزياره ايضا
طبعا الرئيس الصيني عندما وصل اليوم الى
موسكو على مطار في جنوب العاصمه موسكو
تحدث مباشره بان الكثير من الملفات تربط
البلدين وهي ستكون على طاوله الحوار بين
الجانبين ابراهيم يعني اذا ما تم الاخذ
بعين الاعتبار القراءه السياسيه
والتحليلات التي تخرج على مدار الساعه
صحيح ما ذكرته ابراهيم بان الاخبار
العاجله طبعا تملا الان كافه المواقع حول
هذا اللقاء نعم بالفعل التحليل السياسي
باقل من دقيقه تصريحات زياره قد يصل
تصريحات بوتين للرئيس الصيني بانه سنناقش
مبادره بشان اوكرانيا وننظر لها باهتمام
هل هذا يعد مؤشر على ان موسكو ستبدي مرونه
تجاه بنود هذه المبادره التي فيها نقاط
ايجابيه حتى بالنسبه لكيا
يعني قد يصل الموقف ابراهيم كما ترى
القراءه السياسيه في البلاد اليوم وكما
يرى التحليل السياسي لحل الازمه
الاوكرانيه ولو على الاقل تقدير بشكل
مبدئي الاقتراح الصيني درسته موسكو لم
نعرف حتى هذه اللحظه باعتبار انه لم يتم
الاعلان رسميا عن كافه المحاور لكن
الخارجيه الروسيه الكرملين مجلس الامن
مجلس الاتحاد تحدثوا بان في الاقتراح
الصيني العديد من الخيارات التي ترضي
موسكو على ما يبدو ان الجانبين الروسي
والصينيسي يناقشان بعض القضايا ضمن ضمن
هذا الاقتراح التي لا ترغب موسكو
بالموافقه عليها لذلك طبعا كل الخيارات
مطروحه ابراهيم لدى موسكو اليوم على طاوله
الحوار الملف الصيني وقد يخرج الجانبان
يقوم بعده الرئيس الصيني بالاتصال بالرئيس
الاوكراني
ويعد يعني لمقابله او اتصال او يعني
اجتماع عبر تقنيه الفيديو او غير ذلك
لمناقشه ما وصل معه مع الجان ب الروسي
ابراهيم شكرا جزيلا سنكون بالتاكيد
بالمتابعه معك عبد الجواد رشد مراسل
العربيه كنت معنا مباشره من موسكو
وحول ازمه قرار الجنائيه الدوليه بحق
بوتين اعلنت لجنه تحقيق الروسيه عن فتح
تحقيق جنائي مع المدعي العام للمحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه كريم خان بعد ان اصدرت
المحكمه التي تتخذ من لاهاي مقرا لها
مذكره توقيف بحق بوتين واوضحت لجنه
التحقيق انها فتحت تحقيقا جنائيا ضد
المدعي العام للمحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه
والقضاء الذين اصدروا مذكره توقيف بحق
بوتين بتهم تتعلق بارتكاب جرائم حرب مؤكده
ان العديد من قدرات المحكمه استنوا الى
قرار غير قانوني بالسعيي الاعتقاله
في الاثناء اعلنا دبلوماسي اوروبي ان دول
الاتحاد وافقت على خطه لشراء ذخيره
لاوكرانيا بقيمه ملياري دولار او يورو
واضافت دبلوماسي بان الخطه تتكون من ثلاث
مراحل لتزويد القوات الاوكرانيه بما لا
يقل عن مليون قذيفه من عيار
155 ملم
في تطورات الميدانيه اصدرت وزاره الدفاع
البريطانيه بيانا قالت فيه ان القوات
الروسيه تحقق مكاسب في مدينه
الواقعه شمال دونيسك كما اشر البيان الى
ان الوضع التكتيكي فيها يشبه ما يحدث في
باخموت وان المدينه اصبحت مدمره بالكامل
واكدت الدفاع البريطانيه كذلك ان القوات
الاوكرانيه تواصل الدفاع بثبات عن المدينه
نشرت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه لقطات الاعمال
القتاليه لاطقم مدافع في منطقه العمليه
العسكريه الخاصه حيث ضرب الجنود الروس
المواقع الخفيه للقوات الاوكرانيه
[موسيقى]
نشرتنا مستمره وتتابعون فيها بعض الفاصل
بعد يومين من زيارته القاهره وزير
الخارجيه التركيه يقول اذا مصر لا ترتاحوا
لوجود بلاده في ليبيا
اهلا بكم من جديد في تداعيات معتبره صدمه
عالميه بعد انهيار مصر
فيما تراجعت اسعار النفط الى ادنى مستوى
لها في خمسه عشر شهره وصمخاوف احتمال ان
تؤدي اضطرابات القطاع المصرفي العالمي الى
ركود حيث عززت هذه المخاوف رفع احتمال او
محتمل لاسعار الفائده في الولايات المتحده
هذا الاسبوع
اذا نتحول مباشره لمتابعه جانب من كلمه
رئيسه البنك المركزي في البرلمان الاوروبي
حول الازمه المصرفيه الراهنه
انها ماساه حقيقيه في اوكرانيا
انسانيه لشعبي اوكرانيا وفي وجه هذه
الاعمال الشنيعه فقد اظهر الشعب الاوركاني
مرونه وعزيمه عاليتين اقتبسا رئيس اسبق
للبرلمان الاوروبيه خازيه ماريا
والذي توفي للاسف قبل شهر وقال
ان المستقبل هو لمن هؤلاء المستعدين بدل
جهود الاصغاء الى اصوات الامل
وبصفتنا اوروبيون يجب ان نستمع ان نستمر
بالاصغاء الى اصوات الامل من اوكرانيا
وندعم الشعب الاوكراني في كفاحهم من اجل
الحريه والديمقراطيه والسلام والقيام
الجوهريه التي تمثل اتحادنا بات جليا بان
التضامن وبشكل خاص في هذه الازمه يجعلنا
اكثر قوه ومرونه فيجب ان سمر برعايه
قدراتنا على التصرف معا وبشكل جماعي ولا
اثبت كفاءته وفعليته خلال العام الماضي
لقد تمكنا من تقليص اعتمادنا على انابيب
الغاز الروسيه بحوالي 80% واسعار الغاز
عاده الان الى مستويات اقل من التي
شهدناها قبل الغزو
وفي كلمه اليوم مناقشه تطورات الاسواق
الحاليه وبعد ذلك ان تنتقل لتقييمنا حول
اقتصادي متقاعد قبل ان نوضحها اخر
سياساتنا الماليه وقراراتنا اتخذناها في
الاسبوع الماضي ولكن اسمحوا لي ان اشير
انه في غير ضم هذه تطورات الاخيره من انني
ارحب بعمليه
من قبل السلطات السويسريه هذه الخطوات
الضروريه لاستعاده الظروف الاسواق
المعتدله وتحقيق الاستقرار
في الاسواق وعلينا نذكر باننا نراقب
التطورات السوق عن كتب ونحن مستعدون
للاستجابه عندما كنت ضروريا المحافظه على
استقرار الاسعار والاستقرار المالي في
منطقه اليورو
منطقه اليورو وقطع البنوك مرن
وفيها راس مال وسيوله قويا
وفي اي حادثه فان عده ادوات البنك المركزي
الاوروبي معدل بالكامل لتوفير الدعم
بالسيوله لمنطقه اليورو ومنظومتها الماليه
ان كان ذلك ضرووريا وللمحافظه على
الانتقال السلس لسياسه الماليه
اقتصادي منطقه اليورو وسياساتها الماليه
الاخيره
المخرجات كانت افضل بقليل ما توقعناه في
ديسمبر ولكن
الطلب المحلي والخاص انخفض بشكل النحاد
نسبه تضخم العاليه
والغموض وتضيق الظروف الماليه
قلصت الاستثمارات والاستهلاك الخاصه والخط
بحوالي 9%
و3.6 بالمئه
مع تقليص المخاوف حول اعزاء الطاقه وزياده
الاسعار هذه هي العوامل الى الجانب الدعم
المستمر من قبل السياسات الماليه والمرونه
المستمره لاسواق العمل من المتوقع ان تدعم
التعافي خلال الارباح هذا العام القادما
وبالتالي فان النمو المتوقع لعشرين 23 رجع
لاصل الى واحد بالم
الاستحواذ باكثر من ثلاثه مليارات دولار
[موسيقى]
هذه السندات تم ايجادها كالفكره بعد
الازمه الماليه العالميه 2008
واطلق عليها
النقال عليها وكان الغارت منها هي امتصاص
الخسائر في حاله حدوث ازمات حاده كما تحدث
الان وتكون هي الجزء الاول او الفرسلاير
بامتصاص الخسائر حتى لا يتاثر المذيعين
وغيرهم من حمله السندات الاعلى المساهمين
في هذه الحاله بيتم
الخطاب راس مال الشركه الى حد كبير وهذا
الحد هو الذي
يبدا عنه
هذه السندات فبالتالي بنقول هم اللير
الاولاني او الشريحه الاولانيه هم الكوكوز
وبعد هذا ياتي المساهمه
فبالتالي ماذا حدث بقى في هذه الاسهم هذه
الاسهم من يمتلكها يمتلكها كثير جدا من
الهاي او
المؤسسات التامين وغيرها لانها تدر عائد
مرتفع
[موسيقى]
ورغم الاضطرابات التي صاحبت ازمه انهيار
البنكين في امريكا اكد البنك المركز
الاوروبي أن القطاع المصرف الاوروبي مرن
والسيول النقديه قويه قبل ذلك في خطوه
لتوفير السيوله الدولاريه في عقاب الازمه
تم التنسيق بين اكبر سته بنوك مركزيه في
العالم وهي الفيدرالي وبنك كندا وبنك
انجلترا والمركز الاوروبي وسويسري
والياباني لتسهيل وصول البنوك العالميه
الى الدولارات وتفادي حصول اي شحف في
السيوله
والمزيد المتابعه انضم الى باريس الباحث
الاقتصاد الدكتور دانيال ملحم اهلا بك
دكتور دانيال بدايه اجراءات السلطات
الرقابيه سواء كانت في امريكا او في
اوروبا برايك هل ساهمت في الحد من حاله
العدوى والرعب في القطاع المصرفي بغض
النظر عن اداء الاسواق في المنطقتين اليوم
تحيه لك يا سيدي والمرشدين الكرام في
الادوات الرقابيه في اوروبا لنبدا في
اوروبا الادوات الرقابيه السابقه والحاليه
وتدخل مصرف الحالي لا يزال اليوم محور
نجاح لانه عمليا
المشكله الرئيسيه اليوم هي فيما يتعلق
بالقواعد التنظيميه والقواعد الرقبيه في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه في اوروبا
نجحت اليوم الامتصاص هذه الصدمه على
اعتبار ان القواعد الصارمه على البنوك
الاوروبيه هي قاسيه جدا
والبنوك المركزيه او البنك المركزي
الاوروبي يطلب من البنوك الاوروبيه سواء
كانت صغيره ام كبيره
بستريس وبالتكوين ماونات تفوق حجم هذه او
او المخاطر الذي الذي
المنكشف عليها هذه البنوك وبالتالي الى
اليوم لا نزال لنقول ان البنوك الاوروبيه
الى اليوم لا تزال لم يحدث تطور جديد في
الولايات المتحده المشكله في الولايات
المتحده هي مختلفه كليا اليوم نحن نتكلم
عن الكثير من البنوك المحليه المنكشفه
بشكل كبير على على بعض المخاطر وفي بعض
التقارير اللي ظهرت فينيشن التايمز تقول
ان الفيدراليسكو كان لا يزال كان على
اطلاع منذ 2021 على على مخاطر البنك
سيليكون فالي وهذا كلام خطير هذا ما يعني
انه لماذا لم يتدخل
على هذا البنك هل هو اكتفى باعطائه بعض
الارت او بعض الانذارات وبالتالي هو لم
يتدخل بشكل جذري لذلك اليوم السؤال كم بنك
ارسل له بنكسيسكو او الفيدراليه هذه
الانذارات هل هي كميه كبيره من البنوك هذا
هذا التصرف المحاسب الذي كان يعتمده
سيليكون فالي هو كثير من البنوك الصغيره
هذا هو السؤال اليوم لذلك نعم المشكله في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه هي لا تزال
هناك الركض بشكل كبير من البنك المركزي او
الفيدرالي الامريكي لاطفاء الظهر والتخفيض
الطلب على السيوله عن طريق التدخل بشكل
سريع ولكن القاده الكبيره اليوم هي في
مكان اخر سؤالي انه كيف سيتصرف في ظل كل
هذه المعطيات يوم الاربعاء القادم هل
سيذهب الى رفع اسعار الفائده هل ستبقيها
على ما هي عليه سيخفضها كيف سيتجه ربما
قراره من خلال يعني رؤيتكم
اليوم اليوم سيدي الفيدرالي الامريكي امام
ثلاثه
السيناريو الاول ان يتم الرفع بخمسين نقطه
مئويه كما كان معتبرا في السابق وهذا
اشاره سلبيه للاسواق والمصارف والتسجيل
النقدي وبالتالي يمكن ان يؤدي في مكان ما
الى انخفاض في قيمه السندات وخسائر اكبر
وانهيارات اضافيه
الخيار الثاني امام الفيدرالي ان يرفع
الفائده مطلقا وهذه بهذه الحاله هو يكون
قد تخلى هناك الكثير من النداءات اليوم ان
يقول يجب ان يتوقف لبرهه برفع اسعار
الفائده لينظر الى مساد تؤول اليه هذه
الاوضاع ولكن نحن لا يجب ان لا ننسى ان
ارتفاع اسعار الفائده وخاصه عفوا التضخم
وخاصه الكور هو يرتفع بشكل كبير وبالتالي
يجب على الفيدرالي اتخاذ بعض الخطوات
الخطوه المريحه هي عمليا هو الخيار الثالث
او السيناريو الثالث ان يرفع ب 25 نقطه
مئويه لماذا لانه طالما البصره في المركز
او الفيدرالي الامريكي هو يعطي سيوله وفتح
باب السيوله لمده سنه لكافه البنوك
لاحتياجاتها لتغط يه احتياجاتها فهذا يعني
انه يستطيع رفع الفائده بنسبه 25% دون
التاثير على الشروط الماليه للاسواق لو
توضح لمشاهدينا اوجه الاختلاف والشبه بين
الازمتين الحاليه وازمه 2008 باقل من
دقيقه سمعت
نعم المشكله يمكن تلخيصها بثلاثه امور او
التي اعمده العمود الاول هي في سبب
المشكله بشكلها الرئيسي سيدي في
2008 المشكله كانت متشعبه وكانت عالميه
اليوم المشكله هي محليه اثنين البنوك
كان نتكلم عن لمن برادرز وهو بنك تجاري
ومتصل بكافه البنوك العالميه اليوم هناك
بنوك محليه والايكو سيستم تبعها محلول
وبالتالي لا انكشاف على البنوك الكبيره في
العام 2008 ايضا
الحكومات او الفيدرالي والمركزي تاخر
كثيرا بالتدخل في افلس اليوم هناك تسارع
كبير عمليا لاعاده بناء الثقه في المصرف
المركزي والتدخل وبالتالي كبح الذعر وسحب
السيوله من المصارف وبالتالي هذا الثلاثه
اختلافات وهذا لا يعني اليوم انه لا يمكن
ان يكون هناك عدوى او يكون ان تؤدي الى
ازمه المشكله اليوم بالبنوك الكبيره انها
تتخلي بكميات كبيره
لكن النتيجه يمكن ان تكون واحده اذا ما
زادت حاله من الذعر في الاسواق وايضا بين
المذيعين شكرا جزيلا على وجودك معنا من
باريس الباحث الاقتصاد الدكتور دانيال
ملحم
الى اسرائيل حيث اعلن رئيس الوزراء بنيام
نتنياهو تخفيفا لخطه الاصلاح القضائي التي
تبنتها حكومته وحسنه نياهو المعارضه على
اعاده التفكير في المشروع بعدما تعهد
بمقاطعه التصويت عليه في الكنيست وشجعت
على خروج احتجاجات وصلت حتى الى صفوف جنود
الاحتياط في وحدات النخبه العسكريه واجهزه
المخابرات
الملاحظ ان التراجع نتنياهو جاء بعد ساعات
من مكالمه هاتفيه اجراها معه الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن والتي اكد خلالها دعمون
التوصل الى حل وسط بشان خطه نتنياهو في
اول تصريح له بشان هذه القضيه وقال بايدن
ان الاصلاحات يجب ان تحترم القيم
الديمقراطيه الاساسيه
الى اجراء اي تغييرات في السلطه القضائيه
من شانها ان تمنح حكومته نفوذا اكبر في
اختيار القضاه وتحد من سلطه المحكمه
العليا في الغاء التشريعات هذه الخطه
اثارت تظاهرات ومواجهات استمرت لاسابيع
حيث وصف معرضها نتنياهو بانه يحاول تقويض
استقلال المحاكم لكن مع تراجع الانتباهما
ابرز هذه التعديلات يظهر مشروع القانون
المعدل انه لا يمكن تعيين اكثر من قاضيين
في المحكمه العليا خلال تصويت اعتيادي في
جلسه واحده بالكنيست كما يتعين اقرار اي
تعينات تتجاوز ذلك موافقه اغلبيه الاصوات
بما في ذلك قاض واحد على الاقل ونائب
معارض واحد من اعضاء لجنه الاختيار
التعديلات الجديده التي تم ادخالها تشير
الى انه سيتم توسيع لجنه الاختيار من تسعه
الى 11 عضوا كما هو مقترح في الاصل لكن مع
تركيبه تمنح الحكومه نفوذا اقل المشروع
الم عدل ايضا استخدم لغه اكثر تحافظا
مقارنه بتلك الوارده في مشروع القانون
الاصلي لكن ما تزال سلطه القضاء في لجنه
الاختيار محل جدل خاصه فيما يتعلق
بامكانيه استخدام معتبر حق النقد تلقائي
على الترشيحات لمنصه القضاء
وفي خطوه يبدو انها تصعدي اعلنت المعارضه
في اسرائيل انها ستقدم طعنا امام المحكمه
العليا ضد مشروع القانون المقدم من
نتنياهو لتعديل قواعد تعيين القضاه فقال
زعيم المعارضه انه سيقدم الطعن في اللحظه
التي سيتم فيها تمرير التعديلات على لجنه
التعيينات القضيه وتشهد اسرائيل احتجاجات
كبيره ضد قانون تغيير النظام القضائي
وانضم الينا من القدس عبر نيسان المحلل
السياسي اهلا بك سيد نيسان عمليا ما الذي
فعله نتنياهو هل تراجع عن خطه الاصلاح
القضائي التي تبنتها حكومته ام انه قام
بتخفيف وتيره سرعه استكمال بنودها
التي
وزير الدفاع
هدد في المحادثات التي اجراها معنى تنياهو
انه في حال لم يتم التوصل الى التسويه مع
المعارضه
بكل ما يتعلق
اصلاحات في القضاء الجهازي فانه يستقيل من
منصبه كوزير الدفاع
ويؤدي ربما الى اشقه الحكومه وذلك بسبب
ما يحدث في صفوف الجيوش الجيش وكما ذكرتهم
ان هناك بعض الوحدات النخبه
وايضا التيارين الذين اعلنوا عن رفضهم من
امكانيه
الحضور في حال تم استدعائهم
للخدمه
[موسيقى]
التطوعيه او احتياطيه
وفي الليكود هناك توتر بين بين المعيدين
وبين المعارضين بهذا الموضوع
وتتعالى في الساعات الاخيره الاصوات في
صفوف اللكود بان على نتنياهو ان يعلن عن
تعليق
كل ما يتعلق بالتصويت في لجنه الدستور
القانون والقضاء
خلف لذلك وكمان ذكرتم في بدايه كلامكم ان
هناك
ستكون ايضا ازمه بين اسرائيل ولايه
المتحده المكالمه التي تحدث بها يوم امس
بايدن مع رئيس الوزراء هي كانت بمثابه
رساله لرئيس الوزراء
وما تضمن هذه الرساله فعلا طيب السؤال
يعني سيد ايلي نيسان اذا كانت انه يعلم
بان هناك معارضه يعني من المعارضه ومن
داخل الائتلاف الذي يستند عليه وايضا من
خارج الولايات المتحده لماذا لم يلتقط
اتصال الرئيس الامريكي كطوق نجاه ويترفع
الخطه برمتها لماذا يحاول المناوره
سيدي حتى الان
وجهت اصبع اتهام لنتنياهو بان وزير العدل
جرير
هو الذي يقوده لان
هدد
يريفين وزير العدل بانه في حال لم يتم
تطبيق كافه بنود الاصلاح في القضاء الجهاز
جهاز القضائي فانه يعلن عن استقامته وربما
يطلب من وزير الماليه الانسحاب من الحكومه
وهذا اثار معدل شكوك او مخاوف لدى نتنياهو
من امكانيه حدود
زعزعه داخل صفوف الائتلاف الان وكما قلت
في بدايه كلابي
هناك ايضا تهديدات من قبل وزير الدفاع
بهذا لانه وزير الدفاع
يرى داخل او في صفوف يعني من كل ما تقوله
نفهم بانه هناك
عدم توحد داخل الائتلاف يعني الائتلاف
منقسم حول عدد من القضايا وبالتالي اذا
وجود نتنياهو بشكل عام مهدد سواء في ظل
هذه الخطه خطه الصح او اي ازمه قادمه يعني
اي هزه ستسقط نتنياهو
ولذلك في الساعات الاخيره وفي ظل المكالمه
التي
جرت بيننا نتنياه وبين بيضا ليله امس
نتنياهو يحاول
التمرين بين المؤيدين في داخل النقود بين
المعارضين بين المؤيدين للذهاب الى تطبيق
الاصلاحات وبين الاصوات التي تعالت داخل
صفوف النكود من ان على نتناول ان يقرر
تجميل او تعليق الاجراءات القضائيه في
لجنه الدستور
والمطالبه من المعارضه طيب انتم اين ترون
الى اين تتجه هذه الازمه كيف سيتصرف
نتنياهو الان من وجهه نظركم
انا حسب اعتقادي انه كان على نتنياهو ان
يعلن انه يوافق على الطرح الذي طرحه رئيس
الدوله لان كل ما تقوم به اليوم الكنيست
بشكل خاص لجنه الدستور برئاسه
الرئيس اللجنه
هذا لا يرضي
المعارضه لان كل هذه القرارات هي تتخذ من
جانب واحد حتى
المعارضه وافقت في الماضي عندما كانوا هم
في سده الحكم على العديد من القرارات التي
تفيد تطبيقها اليوم او رئيس او وزير العدل
اليوم بسبب عدم اجراء المحادثات بين
المعارضه ولذلك المعارضه لا لا توافق على
اي موضوع كما ذكر
ته من حزبي هناك مستقبل يهدد بانه يتوجه
الى محكمه بهذا الموضوع
بهذا القدر دهمنا الوقت سيد ايلي نيسان
كنت معنا من سكايب المحلل السياسي شكرا لك
من القدس
قال وزير الخارجيه التركي ان مصر لا ترتاح
لوجود التركي في ليبيا واضافها تشوش اوغلو
بانه لا وجود انا وجود تركيا هناك لا يشكل
خطر على مصر مشيرا الى انه تم الاتفاق مع
القاهره على مواصله التشاور والتعاون
الوثيق بشان ليبيا وزير الخارجيه التركيه
قال كذلك ان الاتفاقيه البحريه المبرمه
بين انقره وحكومه الوحده الوطنيه الليبيه
ليست ضد مصالح مصر مشيرا الى ان مصر راعت
مصالح انقره حينما ابرمت اتفاقا بحريا مع
اليونان
الخامسه مستمره وتتابعون فيها بعض الفاصل
في فرنسا مزيد من الاضطرابات بسبب قانون
التقاعد والحكومه امام اختبار سحب الثقه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد الى ايران حيث فرضت
الحكومه البريطانيه عقوبات على قائدين
كبيرين في الحرس الثوري بسبب انتهاكات
جسيمه لحقوق الانسان وقال جيمس كليفر لي
وزير الخارجيه البريطاني ان الاجراء ضد
قاده الحرس الثوري الايراني كان يعود
لتورطهم في تمويل القمع الوحشي للنظام
وفرضت العقوبات على خمسه اعضاء في مجلس
اداره المؤسسه التعاونيه بالحرس الثوري
وقائدين كبيرين بالحرس في محافظه اي طهران
في فرنسا بتزامن مع جلسه للبرلمان الفرنسي
بشان التصويت على مذكرتين لحجم الثقه عن
الحكومه بهدف اسقاطها بسبب قرارها تمرير
مشروع تعديل نظام التقاعد تستعد النقابات
لموجه جديده من الاضرابات في محاوله للضغط
على الحكومه للتراجع عن قانونها المثير
للجدل حيث يستعد مراقبه حركه الملاحه
الجويه للبدء في اضراب لينضموا الى
المسيرات احتجاجا على سن التقاعد
القانونيه من 62 الى اربعه وستين عاما
هيئه الطيران المدني الى الغاء 30% من
الرحلات الجويه في مطار اورلي بالاضافه
الى 20% من الرحلات من مطار مدينه مرسيديا
الواقع جنوب فرنسا الرئيس الفرنسي
ايمانويل ماكرون اعرب عن امله بان يسلك
مشروع مسار الديمقراطي حتى النهايه في
خطوه اعتبرت تحديا لرفضي القانون
من باريس فادي الدهوك مراسل العربيه
ليطلعنا على مزيد من التفاصيل فادي بدايه
الى اي مدى ربما هناك توقعات بان تحدث هذه
الجلسه الفرنسيه
ربما حسما او خرقا فيما يتعلق بحجب الثقه
عن الحكومه بعد حوالي نصف ساعه من الان
اهلا ابراهيم فعلا كما ذكرت هذه الجلسه
سوف تبدا بعد اقل من نصف ساعه تقريبا لكن
ليس لها حظوظ كبيره بان تتمكن من اسقاط
الحكومه لان مذكرتي حجم الثقه بحاجه الى
تصويت 287 نائبا اي الاغلبيه حتى تمر هذه
المذكرات حتى الان الامور ضبابيه هناك
تعويل على اصوات الجمهوريين الذين هم
منقسمين حقيقه فيما بينهم بين مؤيدين
لمشروع قانون رفع سن التقاعد الى 64 عاما
ومعارضين له لكن الامور ما زالت في الشارع
ساخنه جدا هناك تظاهرات بدات تخرج في عدد
من المدن الفرنسيه وهنا في باريس ايضا
الان تخرج تظاهر في احد شوارع العاصمه كما
ان طلاب جامعه السربو اليوم او قبل قليل
قرروا البدء بتنفيذ اضراب وعصيان في مبنى
الجامعه الواقع في منطقه تولبياك صوت نحو
الف طالب من هؤلاء على ان يقوموا بهذا
العصيان والان الشرطه تطوق ذلك المبنى
النقابات تعول على حشد كبير وعلى حركه
اضراب تشل الاقتصاد الفرنسي لتشكل الضغط
على الحكومه وبالتالي اجبار الرئيس مكروه
على سحب هذا القانون وهذا الامر متوقع
ووارد بحسب كيف ستكون هذه الحشود يوم
الخميس المقبل في الثالث والعشرين من هذا
الشهر هو الموعد الذي حددته النقبات وايضا
الاحزاب اليساريه التي تدعمها لكي يكون
يوما للاضراب والتظاهر بالاضافه الى
التظاهرات التي تخرج من قبل الطلاب وهذه
التظاهرات هي ربما التي تشكل فرقا هذه
الايام لانها تخرج من دون تنسيق هؤلاء ليس
لهم قائد وبالتالي هم
محررين من الاحزاب ومن النقبات يقومون
بتحركاتهم وحدهم ويشتبكون للتفاوض معهم
جديد للحكومه الفرنسيه انا اشكرك حتى
الساعه على كل هذه المعلومات مراسله
العربيه كنت معنا مباشره من باريس
الرئيس الامريكي السابق المدعي العام في
منهات
بالتدخل في انتخابات رئاسيه حيث اتهمت مده
عام من هاتم بخلق القانون باستخدام ما
اسماه شهاده مشوهه من محامي ترامب السابق
مايكل كوهين الذي مثل الاسبوع الماضي امام
هيئه المحلفين الكبرى في التحقيق حول
مزاعم عن دفع ترامب مبلغ من المال لاسكات
سيده خلال حملته
الانتخابيه عام 2016
بجانبها قالت محاميه الرئيس الامريكي
السابق الينا هابا ان ادعاءه الاخير بشان
اعتقاله ليس تكهنا واضافتها لشبكه سي ان
الامريكيه بانه على علم بتسريبات من مكتب
المدعي العام بشان مزاعم التقارير الماليه
الاحتياليه من قبل منظمه ترامب قائله انها
سعيده بحديث رفض عن الامر لانه اذا كان
ذلك صحيحا فعليا فعليه ان يستبرقه على حد
تعبيرها
ومع اثاره رمب الامكانيه اعتقالها
المحتمله يبدو انه بدا حملته الرئاسيه
مبكرا بشكل موسع في مواجهه خصومه فبحسب
صحيفه بوليتيكو الامريكيه فان ترامب حول
لائحه الاتهام وشيكا الى اختبار حقيقي
لاعضاء حزبه لاسيما مع خصومه المحتملين في
انتخابات الفين واربعه وعشرين فباتت
القضيه اما الدفاع عنه او وصف من يقف عكس
ذلك
بالمتعاطف مع اليسار بالطبع في اشاره الى
الديمقراطيين الذين قالوا انه لا احد فوق
القانون حيث اتهموا ترامب باذكاء
الانقسامات السياسيه سرعان ما التقط زعماء
حزب ترامب الخيط ودفعوا عنه فرغم انتقادات
وجهها لترامب منذ ايام بسبب هجوم
الكابيتال وقف نائب الرئيس الامريكي
السابق مايك بينس بالاضافه لزعيم
الجمهوريين في الكونجرس كيفن ارثي وكفاء
ضد اي محاكمه جنائيه للترمب وبحسب الصحيفه
فان ترامب اكبر المستفيدين من توقيت اثاره
الازمه سياسيا فهي بمثابه بدايه حقيقيه
للانتخابات ازاحه خصومه الديمقراطيين او
حتى من داخل حزبه في اشاره الى حاكم
فلوريدا روند سنتيس الذي فضل الصمت تجاه
مزاعم ترامب الاخيره
الى هنا من واشنطن المراسل العربيه حسين
اهلا بك حسين بدايه هل هناك اي مؤشرات
تؤكد او تنفي امكانيه اعتقال الرئيس
الامريكي السابق فهمت غدا
تحيه لك ابراهيم اليوم من المنتظر ان يمثل
امام هيئه المحلفين الكبرى في نيويورك
المحامي روبرت وهو كان
محاميا وايضا مستشارا قانونيا لمحامي
ترامب السابق مايكل
حسب ما علمنا ابلغ محاميه ترامب بان لديه
معلومات قد كل ما قاله كاهن وقد يبرئ تراب
من هذه القضيه طبعا اذا تم ذلك بالفعل فمن
المستبعد ان يتم توجيه تهم للترامب من
المستبعد ان يتم اعتقاله غدا كما هو متوقع
كما توقعت نفسه ولكن اذا لم يستطع تقديم
ادله على ذلك فمن المحتمل ان يكون هناك
اجراء اجراء تقديم الاتهام او توجيه
الاتهام
بطبيعه الحال المدعي العام طلب من كوهن ان
يكون حاضرا ومستعدا ليضحض ويقدم نقض شهاده
نقد لكاستي
مثله امام الهيئه كما هو متوقع اليوم
الانظار الان
تتجه نحو ما سيقوله روبرت كاستيو وماذا
سيفعله وماذا سيقدمه لهيئه الكبرى في
نيويورك لنعرف بالفعل ماذا سيجري ردود
الفعل السياسيه حتى الساعه خصوصا داخل حزب
الجمهوري على كل ما يحدث حسين لو تجبلها
لنا
بشكل عام اذا استثنينا رونددس سانتوس
ولكيلي اللذان التزمها الصمت جميع
الجمهوريين دافعوا عن ترامب وحتى ان قبل
مكارتي رئيس مجلس النواب في الولايات
المتحده طالب او قال انه سيوجه اللجان
واللجان الفرعيه ذات الصله بالتحقيق ما
اذا كانت هناك اموال في دلاليه قد استخدمت
في هذا التحقيق
حسب قوله لتقويه الديمقراطيه الجمهوريون
واضحون انهم يدافعون عن ترامب طبعا معظمهم
رفض التظاهر ان هذا امر لا يستدعي التظاهر
رغم انهم قالوا ان التظاهر حق في الدستور
ولكنهم قالوا انه لا يجب ان يكون هناك
تظاهرات اما عن الجانب الديمقراطي بطبيعه
الحال اللي
السيناتور الديمقراطيه قالت انه هذا ايضا
يجب ان لا يتم التظاهر من اجله بالنسبه
لهذا الاحتجاج حتى هناك اخر قال بان لا
احد فوق القانون ولذلك هناك جدل كبير الان
في الكونغرس الامريكي بين الحزب الجمهوري
والديمقراطي الحزب الديمقراطي حول هذا
شكرا جزيلا لك حسين مراسل العربيه كنت
معنا مباشره من واشنطن
شكرا لكم مشاهدينا على متابعتكم للخام
سنلتقي مجددا غدا بحول الله الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]